[Music]
thank you
one of the things that makes us
fundamentally human is that we have this
curiosity about our own biology about
kind of what accounts for our existence
on Earth you can place any human you
know whether they're you know a baby or
they're you know 90 years old and and in
a room and and they'll find something to
be curious about in that room and then
leveraging that understanding to create
technology that actually improves our
condition
my work focuses on on people who have
had arm amputations I want to be able to
grant them back all of the independence
and motion and control of uh of our
prosthesis that they would have had with
an intact lens I'm working on building
soft flexible probes for interfacing
with the brain and studying brain
activity I'm working on this really
beautiful molecular syringe called the
contractile injection system so we
specifically work on prosthetic limbs
exoskeletons so this is a bundle of some
of our fiber you know even though it
looks a little gross on the outside it's
actually quite a beautiful system this
is the Luke arm the Luke arm is the the
hardware device that we work on it's one
of the most advanced robotic upper
extremity prostheses so we were able to
successfully reprogram this this
contractile injection system to Target
human cells and deliver therapeutic
payloads specifically into human cells
I think what
is that we have
thoughts and and memories and problem
solving skills but we're also we have
emotions and creativity the way humans
do it is that they create they're
creative right they make art they can
make music I grew up a musician so I've
been studying music for a long time and
think about music and what makes music
so memorable why is it that you know you
hear a song and it brings you back to a
time of like you know car rides with
friends or you know losses of loved ones
that sort of thing and somehow that is
all arising out of this complex Symphony
of activity within billions of neurons
inside your brain how does the brain
do all of this Rich computation that
we're talking about on such a limited
energy and space budget I'm interested
in how do your life experiences affect
our memory and perception and vice versa
how does your perception affect your
memory all of this you know mechanistic
stuff It ultimately supports
these beings that are full of light and
and poetry and and music
before I came to MIT I was actually a
law student as I was in law school it
turned out that a lot of the more
interesting questions seem to hinge on
an understanding of the human mind I
think what sets us apart as humans is
our social and moral mind which
basically tells us how to treat others
and how to behave in a social world
there's this age-old question that's
that's driven
legal academics and lawyers for a long
time which is
how do judges make decisions I want to
know when things go wrong how do we
intervene to influence and change others
behavior and sometimes you fail to do so
and I want to know why and how to fix it
I do when you're people who are
afflicted by addiction I think most
people probably do maybe they're not
aware of it
when people are in pain pain takes over
everything one question we're asking is
how the brain changes during the cycle
of addiction how does stress impact our
brain function we don't really know
exactly why some people experience
Phantom limb pain but we have some idea
and so I'm really thinking about you
know the hows and the whys and like the
what context you know make someone
either rise to the occasion of stress or
really crumble addiction kind of starts
to to make us question you know what is
Free Will versus what is not you know we
can't eliminate stress from our lives
but what we can change is how we
perceive that stress and how we perceive
our abilities to take on that stressor
try to innovate and try to discover and
try to to invent new things that makes
us overcome our physical and cognitive
limitations
language is exciting because it's a
window into the mind it's a window into
thought I'm a language researcher so I
have to say that What Makes Us special
is language I think it's you know a deep
need to feel other minds and to
communicate with them communicating your
ideas and
communicating your emotions your folks
and not just communicate but be
understood have them really hear you
around 30 percent of autistic children
is a non-verbala or minimally verbal the
question I'm trying to answer is uh how
can we create a technology that's able
to translate these sounds into emotions
or like a more understandable Concepts
language is really specialized and
separate from other kinds of cognitive
functions so now we can take this
insight and apply it in the area of
artificial intelligence
I think being human-like is something
any computational system given the
appropriate resources could achieve
specifically we now see these new models
these large language models that are
trained on huge amounts of text and we
want to know what it is that they are
good at versus bad at are these models
models of language or models of thought
it's less a question of can we achieve
in a smaller questions like you know is
that something that we should try and do
because I I definitely think it's
possible it's exciting to see that our
work on human cognition now has
implications for AI but to me personally
the goal is still to understand the
human mind
thank you